une autre polémique qu'on va parler
maintenant elle n'est pas close non plus
c'est celle ouverte par ses tweets de
responsable de l'unef le syndicat
étudiant en voici un sans vouloir en
faire trop de publicité non plus on le
voit à l'écran je m'en fiche de notre
dame car je m'en fiche de l'histoire de
france
wallah vous aimez trop l'identité
française c'est votre délire de petits
blancs c'est signé hafsaas car qu'est
vice présidente de l'unef à lille et
jusqu'à présent aucune sanction n'a été
prononcée contre eux par le syndicat en
tout cas en rendu public
ça vous inspire quoi père françois paoli
d'abord du mépris et ensuite ça
m'inspire la réflexion suivante et merci
à twitter
parce que quand on nous dit que c'est un
dérapage c'est pas du tout un dérapage
ces véritables c'est révélateur danse
les jambes l'unef de la direction de ce
mouvement qui sont des gens francophones
ce qui était intéressant est ce qu'on
peut globalisé comme ça à dire lui
l'unef s'est pas tout l'une est lent
mais on jamais globalisé les généraliser
mais vous savez c'est ça me fait penser
à ce qu'on appelle les lapsus et les
symptômes en psychanalyse c'est un acte
une parole c'est un acte parole comme ça
c'est un axe et performatif c'est un
acte
c'est un acte politique et ce qui est un
très très intéressant de savoir si de
lire les articles étrangers dans tous
les articles que j'ai lu temps jadis et
l'identité française qui est frappée
symboliquement parce que pour les
italiens pour les américains c'est
évident que dans l'île ce qu'on appelle
l'identité de la france y ait une
dimension religieuse une dimension
chrétienne qui n'est pas contestable
fabrice luchini écrivait hier dans le
figaro je ne suis pas chrétien nous ne
sommes peut-être que chrétien mais la
france est chrétienne
il a raison sur un plan historique ce
monument historique représente la
dimension chrétienne de l'histoire de
france et ce qui est intéressant dans
ses dents c'est petit tweet
outre la nullité intellectuelle que
c'est 8 exprime c'est la haine
elle est de dix mille à elle une part
vous des gens qui habitent ce pays et
qu'il faut bien considérer comme des
gens qui représentent une anti france
qui n'est pas le cas aux états unis
alors ce qui n'est pas aux états unis
aux etats unis le trump combattent les
en titre en piste mais il se combattent
au nom de l'amérique ici
il ya une anti france alors les gens
d'accord c'est un acte politique ou c&a
qi proche de zéro oui moi je suis assez
en désaccord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit d'abord je pense qu'il ya des
polémiques qui ressemble tout à fait à
celle ci aux états unis avec des gens
qu'on accuse aussi d'être anti
américains aujourd'hui
moi moi ce qui me frappe c'est que c'est
d'abord le côté totalement artificiel de
cette polémique fait je vais dire deux
tweets de deux étudiants de l'unef pour
moi ça nous attend des responsables et
terrestres est ce que l'unef existe
vraiment encore enfin si vous voulez
pour moi ces tweets là n'existe pas
jusqu'au moment où on décide de leur
donner une lenteur d'importance mais
bien sûr je trouve que cette polémique
est un caractère complètement
artificielle c'est d'une vacuité
absolument totale et définitive alors il
me françois gaudy c'est quand les
opérateurs d'amener les gens son plaqué
au mur sommé de dire s'il aime la france
ou pas mais je veux dire leur année les
heureusement c'est beaucoup de choses à
la fois notre dame c'est l'identité
chrétienne mais c'est victor hugo
essayez donc tout le monde a son propre
sa propre représentation de notre dame
sa propre représentation de la france
que je voudrais passer ça sous silence
pour vous j'étais content qu'il ait cédé
contre twitter et surtout itélé on peut
pas plaquer les gens au mur en disant
vous êtes pour ou contre vous aimez la
france où vous ne l'aimez pas c'est pas
possible quoi et après juste sur l'unef
je le fais je redis on est déjà dans un
pays où les syndicats sont plus très
représentatifs alors dans le monde des
syndicat l'unef qui était très lié au
parti socialiste qui commençait avec
complètement effondrée je vois pas moins
l'intérêt de tirer sur des ambulances
tranchant dans le voit l'intérêt qu'il
faut c'est pas rien comme vous je pense
qu'il faut tirer aussi sur les
ambulances que dire de petits blancs
qu'est ce que vous dites et les délires
de petit nom importe ce que vous dit
rien ça vous choquerait pas non moi ce
que si vous voulez je vais pas défendre
et donne la parole aux deux autres et
vous répondrais mais je
c'est pas pour prendre la défense de ses
commentaires ineptes
mais maxime là dessus effectivement ce
tweet là ils sont ils sont méprisables
bien sûr mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit après c'est
la liberté d'expression ils ont le droit
de le dire il peut pas me dirige pour
les d'accord après je suis d'accord avec
vous mais je suis d'accord je suis
contre l'idée de l' auld à neige de 13,8
existe c'est à dire telle expression
après je trouve effectivement qu'on en
fait beaucoup trop par rapport à ses
tweets là que effectivement c'est un
effet de loupe une petite polémique sur
twitter il faut rappeler que twitter ce
n'est pas la vraie vie plus tard c'est
un petit microcosme une bulle un petit
peu fermé et surtout il faut rappeler
effectivement que l'unef ne représente
plus grand chose si vous prenez le
nombre d'adhérents l'unef sur le nom des
étudiants c'est 1%
ils sont passés deuxième dans les
majeures dans la sélection et la la
frange radicale parce que donc oui
pigeon tout de même des syndicats qui
sont plus représentatifs ils sont très
politisés et si vous voulez voir les
employés du passé donc je pense que là
on fait beaucoup de choses pour rien
fait pour le cnct tempête dans un verre
d'eau et autres syndicats je vous donne
la parole ensuite marie-mai autres
syndicats étudiants à l'aune de l autre
bord politique celle unis on va voir ce
que disait ce matin dans figaro vox son
patron olivier vial il dit lui vous
voyez s'afficher et je résume qu'en gros
tous ça c'est l'héritage ou bourdieusien
s'est prêté beaucoup de
l'importance encore une fois tout
samarie je vous demande ça parce que on
l'a vu ensemble pour le tweet dont on
parlait et un précédent la même car il
ya deux ans avait signé un tweet disant
il faut gaz est alors c'était quoi gaz
et où les blancs cette source donc c'est
pas juste un truc d'un soir et ayari
qu'on ne peut pas compter ce nom m'a
effectivement cette dame elle réédite
elle devrait plus haut plus être la tête
ou à la vice-présidence et spécialiste
des syndicats étudiants mais elle avait
ce présidence de de l'unef nombreux
encore une fois sans être spécialiste
des services du syndicat étudiant je
crois que en plus ils ont un problème à
l'unef c'est qu'ils sont complètement
tiraillé entre plusieurs tendances cette
dame elle fait partie de la tendance
radicale donc elle fait une polémique
plus forte en se disant j'en sais rien
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme billard à trois
bandes derrière on va davantage parler
de moi je je sais pas tout ça est
pathétique on disait au début de notre
intervention donne ne faisons pas trop
de publicité grâce à ses cinq minutes
déjà content car voilà date et nous
alors
eh bah nicole elle est encore plus
radical idel dit il faut dissoudre
l'unef qui est devenue un nid d'ultra
gauchistes r34 ce n'est pas aux
syndicats de sanctionner mais à la
justice
alors vous vous dites non il n'y a pas
besoin de faire une action en justice
liberté d'expression sur total quand
alain soral 10 des insanités et il dit
des insanités à mes yeux voilà
aujourd'hui va forcer les condamnés sont
maintenant à présent faire montre cette
tendance qui consiste à punir les gens
juridiquement pour l'heure reçu je suis
d'accord avec vous lui dites aux
contrats de l'ultime rencontre que les
gens expriment ce qu'ils ont sur le
coeur c'est très bien on sait très bien
que ces gens sont islamophile etc
c'est un boulot si fort c'est tout
babineau dudit il faut pas exagérer
polémique pour polémique si on devait
sanctionner trump pour tous ces tweets
moqueurs et liberté d'expression qui dix
fois plus que chez nous alors on veut
pas y passer plus de temps que ça un
autre sujet peut-être plus profond
c'est cette idée que finalement cette ce
grand chantier c'est peut-être une
chance pour les métiers manuels pour
l'artisanat
alors les besoins sont immenses on parle
de 200 couvreur 250
charpentier de samba sont 200 tailleur
de pierre sont les chiffres donnés par
les compagnons du devoir ce matin
c'était à l'issue d'une réunion avec les
trois principaux ministres concernés
pour lancer les chantiers de france pour
la reconstruction de notre dame
alors fallait-il que ce terrible
incendie
enfin ce terrible incendie arrive pour
qu'on prenne conscience de l'importance
de ces métiers on va en parler on va
voir le ministre l'éducation jean michel
blanquer riz les optimistes sur cette
question les côtes on a les bras mais il
en faudra plus il en faudra plus non
seulement pour notre dame de paris mais
pour l'ensemble du patrimoine de france
et je dirais même au delà du patrimoine
de france la france a une occasion parce
que d'un mal doit être un bien la france
a eu l'occasion de sur la base d'un
savoir faire qui est unique au monde
ce savoir-faire qu'incarne très bien les
compagnons du devoir et et qui incarne
bien dans nos métiers nos professeurs de
lycée professionnel et bien ce savoir
faire nous allons le développer d'un mal
on peut faire un bien marié faire
relancer l'apprentissage les métiers
manuels et la carence et l'attrait pour
ce métier alors en tout cas ce qui est
vrai c'est ça va donner un coup de
projecteur là il a raison jean michel
blanquer
ça ça peut devenir une vitrine de la
richesse et la diversité de de ces
métiers là après il ya encore beaucoup
de chemin à parcourir pour que
l'apprentissage et ces métiers là soient
revalorisés de vienne aux yeux des gens
une filière d'excellence
que dans les yeux des parents il ya une
certaine fierté de dire mon fils a fait
fi lière boulangerie parce que les
messins parce qu'il avait une passion
j'ai pas si vous vous souvenez de cette
petite polémique qui avait eu en 2017
c'était antoine frérot qui était patron
de veolia qui maladroitement en faisant
la promotion de l'apprentissage en tant
que président de l'institut de
l'entreprise avait dit oui c'est très
bien il faut encourager les jeunes et la
question lui est posée sur ses enfants
ah oui mais pour mes enfants la question
ne s'est pas posé il était brillant à
l'école voilà patatras voilà
culturellement il ya encore besoin d'un
état d'esprit contrairement à
l'allemagne qui compte 1 contrairement à
tout un tas de pays et puis surtout en
termes de débouchés sont des filières
qui
qui permettent aux jeunes de trouver du
travail de paris à l'issue ce qui n'est
pas le cas dans tout dans toutes les
filières professionnelles
alors on en parle tout de suite mais
pour compléter je vous propose d'écouter
frédéric l'étoffé c'est le co président
du groupement des entreprises de
restauration des monuments historiques
il était hier sur le plateau de figaro
live on écoute bon ce drame on pourra
effectivement espérer faire venir des
jeunes dans nos métiers parce que on en
a bien besoin également cédé métiers
manuels qui sont qui ont été beaucoup
dénigré depuis de nombreuses années
alors on est tous responsables mais nous
parents on a besoin de manoeuvre
d'ailleurs dans tous les métiers pas
forcément uniquement la taille de pierre
mais vraiment tous les métiers liés au
patrimoine à frédéric l'étoffé qui était
l'invité de charlotte darche et qui est
tailleur de pierre de son métier
vous y croyez maxime bailly ben oui
enfin c'est sûr que ça va mettre une
lumière justement sur ces métiers là il
y en a bien besoin après faut pas
oublier non plus qu'on a en france
quarante mille bâtiments qui sont
classés monuments historiques et donc il
ya sur ces bâtiments a déjà beaucoup
d'artisans qui travaille tous les jours
avec de l'argent public avec de l'argent
privé et